now the awards for custom design are
next on the agenda to make these
presentations we have privileged to
introduce a star who wears clothes so
very well she has just been named one of
the 10 best trim best dressed women in
America the prettiest thing that Mike
Todd left out of around the world in 80
days Miss Elizabeth Taylor
the talent imagination research and
industry that go into the design of the
costumes for motion pictures I
frequently rewarded by the adoption of
the cinema styles by audiences all over
the world tonight are gifted designers
are being honored by their
contemporaries the nominees for the
black and white costume design are the
Magnificent Seven
a Toho production Kingsley international
Japanese kalki I saw key the power and
the prize metro-goldwyn-mayer Helen Rose
the proud and profane the perverted
Seaton production paramount Edith Head
the solid gold Cadillac Lum beer John
Dewey teenage rebel 20th Century Fox
Charles lemare and Mary wills the solid
gold Cadillac Tron
for the best achievement in costume
design of a color production around the
world in 80 days the Michael Todd
company you miles playing giant giant
production Warner Brothers Moss Mabry
and Marjorie best The King and I 20th
Century Fox are in sheriff 10
commandments motion picture associates
incorporated paramount Edith Head Ralph
jester Jon Jensen
Dorothy chickens and Arnold Freiberg a
war and peace upon to De Laurentiis
production paramount
Maria do Mattias the King and I are
really sure
and behalf of the sheriff thank you very
much
thank you very much Liz hello boy
this Taylor that's the young lady who
married the very very bright gentlemen
mr. Mike Todd as you know around the
world in 80 days is up for an award but
Mike almost didn't make the picture he
had an argument with Howard Hughes and
you figured a way to get even with him
he bought Asia